et cette affiche que vous montrez a été
a été enlevé tout de suite après parce
que il ya eu le 11 septembre et après le
11 septembre on n'a plus le droit de
mettre cette affiche j'en ai jaquette et
tout ça évidemment les flammes dans la
tour ses fils était effectivement pas 13
heures les flammes et à l'art abstrait
poste ça a été compliqué tiens c'est vos
origines lancé moment là
là ça commence à être le moment où on
nous dit plus je suis arabe là
vous l'a dit ah oui tout le temps même
et on vous a fermé des pas tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps c'est ma vie a commencé là ma vie
a commencé quand j'ai rencontré eric
j'ai commencé à devenir à ne plus sentir
la différence en tout cas où à être
accepté comme un
va être accepté à être vu comme un mec
normal
en fait j'étais j'étais jeune et j'ai
compris que j'étais pas français je le
suivre jusqu'au fou mais je suis
profondément mais j'ai compris un sais
pas où j'étais pas français au premier
contrôle de police c'est assez large
avec on que tu que tu prends le truc
dans la gueule dessus quand tu es enfant
tu vas patinoire squash stills et du
squash
[Rires]
et au polo squash au club avec mes amis
es et tu te rends pas compte et puis
c'est dès que tu commences à avoir une
vie un petit peu de jeunes adultes là
les premiers contrôles de police
les premiers et tout les cv qui te
reviennent quand tout tacle assez prisé
que toi tu es le seul à pas être pris
c'est tous ces premiers signes ou tu
commençais à sentir que tiens t'es pas
été un français mais de seconde classe
et qu'il allait falloir batailler dur
pour
passer en wagon première classe